aus potsdam zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
der historiker sönke neitzel professor
für militärgeschichte und
kulturgeschichte der gewalt an der
universität potsdam grüße sie herr
einzeln
in dieser debatte über deutsche
waffenlieferungen scheinen sich zwei
lager gegenüber zu stehen die einen
sagen deutschland müsse waffen liefern
die anderen wollen das nicht mit dem
argument dass seinen kriegseintritt
deutschlands zwischenlösung des kanzlers
geld für die ukraine mit dem verweis man
solle bei der deutschen
rüstungsindustrie bestellen warum keine
direkten lieferungen
mehr gesehen ja dass die bundesregierung
hin und her laufen wird und wo ein
politischer wille ist es immer auch ein
weg und man erkennt ja das ist
offensichtlich von der bundesregierung
von herrn scholz
keinen wirklichen politischen willen
gibt sich schwere waffen zu liefern mit
diesen dingen gäbe würde man sich auch
wege finden dann würde man über details
sprechen wir reden ja auch nicht darüber
dass letzten alle schützenpanzer marder
und alle geschütze geliefert werden
sollen und ich glaube der hintergrund
ist schlicht die debatte in der spd wir
haben etwa die hälfte der abgeordneten
der spd fraktion die ganz klar gegen
solche waffenlieferungen sind die er für
einen pazifistischen flügel kommen die
andere hälfte ist sang er dafür und
scholz muss das glaube ich ausgleichen
und die das resultat ist dann eine sehr
unglückliche kommunikation
ich glaube dass die deutschen insgesamt
mehr machen als man ja aufgrund der
kommunikation meinen würde und so
schlecht stehen die deutschen gar nicht
da wie die kommunikation ist sehr
unglücklich ist ein hin und her so
kommen zum schluss irgendwie das bild
aus dem deutschen wird nichts also wenn
die von vornherein die bundesrepublik
klar dass strategie hätte was man
liefert mit welchen begründungen man
könnte jetzt auch sagen wir liefern
schwere waffen nicht jetzt sofort aber
wir stellen altbestände zur verfügung
die werden aufgearbeitet also es sind
die signale die kommen sind sehr
unglücklich und dadurch ist das bild das
deutschland abgibt international ein
sehr schlechtes ist das denn
diese kommunikation auch ein umweg um
das ticket kriegseintritt zu vermeiden
und wenn ja warum muss das denn so
unbedingt vermieden werden russland sagt
doch ohnehin man führe krieg gegen die
nato
ja also ich glaube das ist konsens dass
niemand in deutschland oder von den
nato-staaten in diesem krieg aktiv
importiert werden will aber das meint
eben keine nato soldat auch keine
deutschen soldaten in diesem krieg
völkerrechtlich ich bin kein
völkerrechtler aber so weit ist das
verstehen kann man waffen liefern und es
ist kein kriegseintritt und dahin ist
diese ganze waffen debatte defensiv
offensiv waffen ja eine theoretische
weil was unterscheidet letztlich diese
waffen in ihrer wirkung eine
panzerabwehrrakete kann einen bestimmten
szenarien für wirkungsvoller sein als
ein panzer also ich glaube das ist
letztlich ein vorgeschobenes argument
aber weil es sei nicht möglich so schwer
ist innerhalb der kollektion ich glaube
noch mal innerhalb der spd-fraktion
diese waffenlieferungen durchzusetzen
und man sucht dann nach argumenten das
nicht tun sollen und es wäre hier
natürlich besser man hätte von anfang an
nach dem 27 februar nach der
regierungserklärung der zeitenwende
erklärung bekannt dass scholz eine klare
linie gehabt mit klarer kommunikation
andere länder machen das besser machen
nicht notwendigerweise mehr aber sie
machen eben ein klareres bild ab und ich
glaube schon dass deutschland mehr
machen könnte wenn der politische wille
da ist auch jetzige des erklärung
gestern fragt man sich ja warum
eigentlich erst jetzt warum brauchen wir
dafür solange und damit wird sich der
effekt den scholz erzielen will auch den
befreiungsschlag lässt sich nicht
erreicht wie bewerten sie denn diese
diskussionen darum dass man wenn man
mader leopard 1 oder 2 liefern wollte
oder würde erst die ukraine schulen
müsste jetzt hat gestern abend
general de gaulle rams gesagt man könne
da ein schnelldurchlauf machen worum
geht es da in dieser debatte ja also ich
glaube dass der stellvertretende
generalinspekteur laufen zu halten schon
ein punkt hat also ist es nicht so man
setzt sich da einfach ein und fährt los
also man braucht man kann
ausbildungswillig verkürzen aber es ist
angesagt und so bei den malern das ist
will man die liefern würde es ist keine
waffe die man morgen im dom boss
einsetzt sondern die ukraine müssten
dann ist ihre eigene verantwortung dann
kreiert werden und man setzt sie auch
zeigen in der regel in verbänden ein auf
was muss trainiert werden aber auch es
wäre ja trotzdem ein politisches signal
dass er klickt wird ja nicht nächste
woche zu ende sein und wenn die ukraine
das hauptproblem ist dass die ukraine
jetzt hier kriegsmaterial verbrauchtes
verlust allein wird und die frage ist
was ist eigentlich in vier worten was
ist in acht wochen haben wir dann
überhaupt noch schützenpanzer und panzer
die wir einsetzen können darum geht es
eigentlich und ich glaube schon so kann
man die argumente zusammenführen von
herrn rahmens und von einem laufental
ich glaube es ist schon möglich wenn man
das politisch gewollte ukraine einen
solchen schützenpanzern auszubilden und
die gehen dann nicht jetzt an die front
aber in einigen wochen und damit würde
man praktisch signal setzen dass auch
klar ist die zahl um die wir hier reden
ist relativ gering und diese
schützenpanzer machen keinen
entscheidenden unterschied
wenn wir über ein dutzend zwei dutzend
drei dutzend treten wird das diesen
krieg nicht entscheiden es geht hier um
die politische symbolik und deswegen
glaube ich greift die ukrainische
regierung und ukrainische botschafter
auch immer wieder deutschland an sie
können auch andere länder angreifen die
die auch nicht so viel tun aber
deutschland ist sie sagen dass der
schwache wachter teil in der kette weil
in deutschland immer wieder sehr
ungepflegt kommuniziert und wann immer
die anderen die angst hat die deutschen
stellen sich ganz hinten also von daher
offene kommunikation ehrliche
kommunikation wäre besser und könnte
auch sagen wir liefern waffen aber das
ist wahrscheinlich nicht unmittelbar
jetzt für diese abwehr dieser offensive
sondern für einen zeitraum von einigen
monaten aber auch das wäre ja ein signal
vielen dank herr professor für ihre zeit
ca